Ouais
comme à moi
si ces transporteurs cris jours supplémentaires
ces textes que ceux-ci avec leurs textes de
les dommages au confort beaucoup
et
la destruction de toutes ces coutumes
que j'ai mentionné
tu as détruit quand
quand le centre de la violence aujourd'hui à
en avant nous changeons notre combat
ne signifie pas que nous ne nous battrons pas
nous allons nous battre nous devons nous battre mais
avec notre esprit avec notre idéologie
mais
et j'irai
le spirituel maya nous enseigne
que nous ne sommes pas propriétaires
atterrir
elle est notre mère elle possède
nous sommes tes enfants
et il y a une tradition agricole dans le
passé qui est très sage
et nous le faisons mal n'est pas la même chose
nous faisons mal parce que nous vivons ici nous ne sommes pas
d'une autre planète
les graines sont à nous et je pense
personne ne devrait nous impliquer
Nous devons poursuivre cette tradition qui
il vient que d'une récolte nous obtenons le
semer pour un autre et ne pas créer de dépendance
ici en ce moment s'ils nous ouvrent 2 nous mangeons
blettes et ils nous mangeront chipilín
nous mangeons de la laitue
de tout
Non
Ouais
la grande tristesse du peuple
indigène ici est petit
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec les garçons fait
comment allons-nous survivre
ce sont les traditionnels qui vont
pour les sauver et les protéger
sans eux nous n'aurons pas à le faire
c'est donc ce que nous voulons
aller de l'avant avec nos familles
bien vivre ensemble